hallo liebe leute und herzlich
willkommen zurück bei einer neuen
episode kari antwortet endlich sind wir
wieder zurück für euch mit euren
zuschauerfragen losgeht
wir fangen an mit yasuo yamamoto er
kommt aus japan und schreibt hallo kari
ich bin deutsch lehrer an einer uni in
japan und höre seit einigen monaten
regelmäßig easy german obwohl ich schon
59 jahre band und sprech- und lese
deutsch so lange ist es immer noch
schwierig sofort alles beim hören zu
verstehen
deshalb hilft mir die serie easyjet dann
noch ein bisschen er arbeitet auch mit
seinen studenten und er hat auch er hat
auch eine frage für uns und zwar
schreibt yasuo yamamoto
auch ich möchte euch eine frage stellen
im gespräch auf der straße hört man sehr
oft wie wir früher auf keinen fall im
unterricht gelernt haben zum beispiel
attraktive wie cool super oder sogar
mega was mich aber am meisten
überraschte oder schockierte ist das
wort geil
für mich scheint es ein skandal so ein
obszönes vokabular in der öffentlichkeit
auszusprechen ist dieses wort wird
heutzutage wirklich schon
gesellschaftsfähig geworden
ich erwarte dass ihr bald auch dieses
thema behandeln werde ja lieber herr
yamamoto aus japan
tatsächlich ist dieses wort
gesellschaftsfähig ich weiß dass das
wort früher etwas anderes bedeutete geil
also im sinne von sexuell erregt das ist
der ursprung dieses ortes
aber es hat sich über die jahre
gewandelt man hat dieses wort schon vor
vielen jahren vor 20 30 jahren
eigentlich als jugendwort benutzt um
auszudrücken dass etwas cool ist oder
mega oder einfach gut ist und dieses
wort ist es ja immer ein teil dieser
jugendsprache dass man einen wort
benutzt was vielleicht ein bisschen
anstößig ist oder einen kleinen skandal
erweckt das ist heutzutage aber nicht
mehr so es kann gut sein wenn du oder
wenn sie in deutschland deutsch gelernt
haben vor
vor 30 oder 40 jahren dass das wort eine
andere konnotation hatte und auch anders
verstanden wurde das ist vielleicht
damals noch ein kleiner skandal war
heute ist das nicht mehr so das witzig
ist wir haben ja heute zu tage auch
schon wieder neue worte die heute noch
anstößig sind und in 20 jahren
vielleicht entweder vergessen oder auch
völlig normal sind heutzutage weil man
etwas cool findet sagt zum beispiel das
ist porno das hat man vor zehn jahren
oder vor 15 jahren vielleicht auch noch
nicht gesagt kann zum beispiel sagen wo
einst das wetter das wetter ist heute
richtig porno oder ist dass pornos geil
das hört sich vielleicht für deine ohren
etwas komisch an aber tatsächlich kann
man heutzutage so reden und man würde
das vielleicht jetzt nicht offiziell
sagen im unterricht aber unter
jugendlichen am strand auf der straße
auf jeden fall übrigens lieber herr
yamamoto japan ist eines meiner
lieblings länder und ich war noch nie
dort es steht ganz oben auf unserer
liste von ländern die wir unbedingt noch
besuchen wollen und wie sie vielleicht
wissen machen wir ab und zu workshops
waren sie sehr schon in namibia haben
auch in deutschland workshops gemacht
jetzt fahren wir in die usa und nach
ägypten um dort schulen und
universitäten zu besuchen
vielleicht haben sie ja auch mal lust
uns einzuladen und wenn das so ist dann
schreiben sie uns doch einfach mal eine
e mail an info at the german dot org und
vielleicht sehen wir uns ja mal und
vielleicht machen wir meinen workshop
zusammen in japan dafür wirklich der
knaller oder also uns wird das sehr
freuen
wir werden gucken ob wir das irgendwie
hinbekommen edgardo gomez schreibt uns
hallo liebe kari vielleicht könntest du
den unterschied zwischen den verben
ändern und verändern erklären
der unterschied ist mir immer noch
unklar dank im voraus und viele grüße
aus honduras ja viele grüße nach
honduras danke dass uns geschrieben hast
edgardo der unterschied ich habe gerade
schon mit janisch überlegt ist auch für
uns gar nicht so einfach denn die sind
sehr sehr
also es geht beides immer etwas ändert
sich change aber vielleicht kann man
verändern etwas langfristiger sehen es
ist ein prozess
man kann zum beispiel sagen wenn man
jetzt etwas kurzfristiges nimmt kann man
auf beides benutzen also oft stehen die
beiden synonym zum beispiel die
windrichtung hat sich gerade geändert
oder die windrichtung hat sich gerade
verändert das kann man beides sagen aber
man kann zum beispiel nicht sagen wenn
ich jetzt sagen möchte auch in den
letzten 20 jahren hat sich diese insel
sehr verändert dann würde ich verändern
benutzen weil ich beschreibe diesen
längeren prozess also eine sache
eine person kann sich ändern und
verändern
kurzfristig sagt man er ändern
langfristig sagt man er etwas hat sich
verändert
abdul haha das bestimmt abbilde in
hamburg wohnt schreibt hallo ich muss
das leider fragen warum machen die
deutschen beim schnupfen sehr laute
stimme wie ihre nase runter fallen würde
ich konnte leider noch nicht verstehen
warum schreibt abdullah abdullah mainz
niesen oder wenn ich das richtig
verstehe das waren deutsche tatsächlich
sehr laut 90 x ja macht das auch sehr
laut ist kannst du uns die frage
beantworten
und zwar beim niesen geht es darum die
keime dem aus dem organismus heraus zu
posten
es geht darum also die nase frei zu
machen von denen von den bakterien von
den keimen stimmt das also das halte ich
für ein gerücht aber ich weiß nicht
macht man das in anderen ländern leyva
erzählt uns doch mal wie ist das in
aller welt mir ist das ehrliche sache
noch nicht aufgefallen ich weiß auch
dass mein vater und janosch beide sehr
laut niesen also ich mache und die
machen ja danke für diese interessante
frage abdul schön dass wir das in
deutschland aufgefallen
mister letten hat möchte gern wissen
hallo dieses projekt ist echt toll und
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen wie viel
zeit verbringen müsste diese videos zu
machen viel zeit
minister laschet einigen menschen
gefragt ob es in zukunft untertitel für
die kari antwortet episoden geben wird
habt ihr gehört dass youtube in letzter
zeit geändert hat so dass zuschauer
jetzt eure videos unter beitragen können
ja das haben wir gehört ist das eine
möglichkeit fragt mister letten
wir haben das natürlich gehört dass es
unter den griff haben es auch schon
ausprobiert
allerdings ist es so dass wir das
natürlich auch selber bedienen müssen
das heißt erstens man kann die
untertitel in einer fremdsprache nur
dann hinzufügen wenn es die deutsche
transaktion gibt es könnte natürlich
sein dass jemand von euch so gedeutet
kann oder vielleicht deutscher ist er
das selber machen möchte das müssen wir
natürlich erst mal rein stellen das
müssten auch kontrollieren ob es korrekt
ist dann kann man fremde untertitel
hinzufügen
wir haben das gefühl dass es genauso
viel arbeit ist wie die selber zu machen
weil wir müssen im prinzip jeden tag
prüfen ob jemand was eingereicht hat und
wenn wir dann irgendwie 20 30 40 videos
anlagen haben ist das schon tatsächlich
zusatzarbeit jeden tag 1 1 2 stunden und
das haben wir einfach im moment nicht
aber wir können ja mal gucken also ihr
könnt euch nochmal schreiben werde sich
daran beteiligen möchte wenn wir
tatsächlich auch deutsche
muttersprachler hätten die dabei
mithelfen könnte das eine option sein
also schreibt uns gerne mal wenn das für
euch interessant wäre damit zu machen
weil mustafa schreibt hallo kari hallo
janosch sagt man die paprika oder das
paprika oder der paprika und was ist die
plattform danke janisch das paprika ich
weiß ist nur die afrika kann es sein
dass man das unterschiedlich verwendet
weil es gibt einige worte wo die
deutschen selber drüber streiten und
auch leute andere generationen andere
städte das anders machen zum beispiel
immer streit ist der nutella oder die
nutella oder dass nutella oder die
joghurt oder das joghurt das laptop und
der laptop die e mail und das e mail der
blog oder das blog also es gibt sehr
viele worten und das sind immer worte
die nicht aus dem deutschen ursprünglich
kommen also wenn wir die worte von
außerhalb nehmen dann ist man manchmal
unklar und manche leute sprechen dass
auch unterschiedlich aus ich sage auf
jeden fall die paprika und plural die
paprikas ernst was hast du richtig
letzte frage kommt von amnesie amnesia
shadows kay tomas von keppel world
productions wir kennen dich natürlich am
niederschreibt dieses video war echt
lustig und meint unser letztes dana und
kari antworten
ich habe eine frage wenn du ein
küchengerät wäre ist was du wärest du
bitte erklären
ja danke für diese sehr interessante
frage am ja da habe ich natürlich sofort
eine antwort darauf die ich die auch
erklären kann ich wäre gerne ein mixer
warum weil der mixer sehr viel power hat
er kann alles kaputt machen aber er kann
auch alles vereinen
na was sagst du zu dieser antwort was
ich bin schon so gespannt auf deine
antwort was wärest du denn gerne welches
küchengerät schreibst uns in die
kommentare
und auch an alle von euch schreibt uns
mehr fragen schreibt uns eure antworten
in die kommentare
wir freuen uns auf euch und schöne grüße
von der wunderschönen insel sylt und bis
bald wieder bei carry antwortet und zwar
aus berlin aus dem studio
ja und wie
gleich los
vorher noch kurz wir haben ja
die studios haben aufzufahren